字幕: Yurie Yamane
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさん こんにちは
ブルースと申します
（拍手）
54歳のアメリカ人です
先程の素敵なプレゼンテーションを見て
私も つい踊りたくなったのですが（笑）
踊りは非常に下手ですから しません
ご安心ください
代わりにワインの話をしましょう
私は 数十年前から
ワインの仕事を続けています
最初はニューヨークで ワインの販売 —
ソムリエの仕事をしていて
その後カリフォルニアに引っ越して
カリフォルニアで
ワイン造りの仕事を始めました
ワイン造りはカリフォルニア、オーストラリア
ニュージーランド、フランス、最後は日本 —
日本では 二十数年前から
ワインを造っております
この数十年 ワイン漬け人生を過ごしてきて
ワインについて 色んなことを
思うようになりました
１つはワインというものは
幅広く いろんな分野に接してる
パッと考えるとワインって
美味しいお酒ですね
だと思っているんですけど
皆さんも そう思っているといいと思いますが
それより もう少し深く考えると
やはり西洋の食文化で存在感のあるもの
近いうちに日本の食文化にもなると
うれしいです
だけど もっとたくさんの
分野に関係しています
例えば サイエンス、医学
栄養学、微生物学など
実は歴史、芸術、技術
もちろん農業にも関係しています
私はどちらかというと 少し —
ADHD（注意欠陥・多動性障害）っぽい
タイプですから（笑）
ワインを通じて色んなことを
経験できるのは非常に魅力で
それで 私はワインの虜になりました
でも 今日は
その話をしようとは思っていません
まったく違うところ —
普段 ワインとまったく関係ないことを
話していこうと思っています
自分のワインの経験を
振り返ってみると
意外と不思議で その[経験の]特徴は
[始め]からできていたものです
それはワインのもう１つの面に
社会を動かす力があることです
このことを初めて経験したのは
ワイン業界に入ってすぐ —
ニューヨークで
ワインの販売をしていたころです
ニューヨークは当時も今でも
世界のワイン市場のトップの１つです
世界中の生産者が 自分のワインを
ニューヨークで売りたいと考えています
私が勤めていた酒屋さんの棚は
ワインであふれるほどでした
ほぼ すべてのワイン原産国のワインが
棚に肩を並べていました
ただ 私が今 「ほぼ」と言ったのは
実は１つの国のワインが
棚に置いてなかったからです
わざとです
それは南アフリカのワイン
南アフリカは当時 1970年代に
人種差別的なアパルトヘイト制度を
施行していた国でした
われわれスタッフは —
基本的に
南アフリカのワインを販売すれば
アパルトヘイトをサポートしているのと
同じことに —
同じことになると思ったので
まず南アフリカのワインを
扱うことをやめて
その代わりに 南アフリカのワインを
置いておくはずの棚に
小さな表示を 置きました
この表示でした
もちろん ニューヨークの酒屋さんでしたから
英語の表示でしたが
日本語訳にすればこのようなもの
つまり —
「アパルトヘイトに反対ですので
南アフリカのワインを扱いません」
この表示を棚に置いたら
お客さんが見るかどうか —
気づくかどうか
わからなかったのですが
反応が強くすぐに 出たんです
必ずしも良い反応とは
残念ながら言えません
あるお客さんとの会話を
今でも思い出せますが
その人はその表示を読んで —
自分は その日１本買って帰って
奥さんと飲もうと思っていたので —
「なぜ私が この国際的な陰謀に
絡む必要があるのか」と怒りました
だけど 大部分のお客さんの反応は
良いものでした
みなさん表示を読んで
自分の毎日の行動によって
遠く離れている人にも
悪影響が出ると気づいて
会話のきっかけとなりました
お客さんとアパルトヘイトや人権など
いろんな話ができました
非常によかったです
最後には 南アフリカの
アパルトヘイト制度は崩壊しました
南アフリカに住む全ての人が 基本的人権を
法的に受けることになりましたが
私たちがニューヨークでやったことは
それとはまったく関係ありません
もちろん 影響はゼロだと思います
南アフリカは遠いですから
でも 少なくとも私たちの
ワインレベルのコミュニティ —
ニューヨークのコミュニティでは
私たちがしたことは響いたと私は信じます
その次に 社会的意味のあることを
ワインの仕事でできたのは
かなり時間が経ってからです
ニューヨークの後
私はカリフォルニアに引っ越して
ワイン造りの業界に入りました
ワイン醸造コンサルタントに
最後にはなりました
醸造コンサルタントとして
いろんなワイナリーと働いて
各ワイナリーの製品の品質を
レベルアップをするために
いろんな技術指導をさせてもらいました
そのきっかけで ある日
日本のワイナリーから
問い合わせの電話が入りました
自分のテリトリーのカリフォルニアから
日本はあまりにも離れているので
最初は断ろうとしたのですが
その日本のワイナリーの代表は
かなり粘り強い奴で
何回も電話がかかってきた
電話の内容は 大体は その人による
自分のワイナリーの説明でした
その話を聞いたら だんだん
[自分の] 中から 興味が湧いてきました
そのワイナリーは
栃木県の足利市にある小さな
「ココ・ファーム・ワイナリー」
というところで
ココ・ファームはいろんな
面白いことをやっていますけど
１番面白いことは
そのワイナリーを作った
もともとの理由が
知的障害を持つ方たちの 職場として
ワイナリーと畑ができたということ
意外と面白い話だと思いました
これをすべて始めたのはこの方です —
園長先生 川田昇（かわだのぼる）様
園長先生が 障害を持つみなさんの
リハビリとして農作業に目をつけた —
ハンディキャップを持つ人と一緒に
屋外の労働の仕事をやれば
全体的に元気な身体ができるんじゃないかと
園長先生が考えて
「こころみ学園」
という小さな施設を先に作りました
その「こころみ学園」でみなさんが
一緒に暮らして農作業をやってた
その中の農産物の１つがブドウでした
生食用 ―
食べるブドウですけど
でも やはり ―
ブドウ栽培をやっていたのはプロではなくて
福祉関係の先生などという人たちで
ブドウ作りの中では
かなりできの悪いものが出ました
ワイナリー専門語を使うと
「くずブドウ」ということですけど
房の形が変なものとか
虫食いの入っているブドウとか
そういうものもでました
それは売り物にならないので
普段困っているんですが
園長先生がお酒好きなものですから
そのまま取っておいて
自家製ワイン —
つまり「密造」してた —
（笑）
内緒ですけど
もう亡くなった方なので
大丈夫ですけど
でも それもやはり ―
園長先生がそれを数年連続でやってから
営業的にワイン醸造と販売をしようと決定して
ワイナリーを立ち上げました
それも友だち同士で飲む自家製ワインと
お金で売るワインの製品のレベルが違うから
最初は上手くできず
それで 私が呼ばれました
自分の元の職業のワイン造りと
まったく関係ないと思っていた —
福祉関係の仕事との組み合わせが
非常に面白いから
私は 最終的に 「じゃあ ちょっと
日本に顔を出してみよう」と思いました
二十数年前でした
最初は 日本に来て
プラスマイナスを感じたのです
個人的にはココ・ファーム・こころみで
勤めたことはすごくよかった
なぜかというと 私は知的障害の皆さんと
すごく仲が良かったから
当時は気づいていませんでしたが
皆さんの目から見ると
私は同じレベルだったんでしょうね
外国人が日本に来ると
最初は言葉ができないし
自分の感じていることは伝えられないし
周りの行動が理解できないから
まるでハンディキャップの人でした
仲間として迎えてくれたのが
すごくよかったです
仕事の面はどちらかというと
そんなには納得しませんでした
日本のワイン造りの条件 —
ブドウの品種、気候、土壌
そしてワイン消費の文化が
自国のアメリカ、カリフォルニアや
オーストラリアやヨーロッパで
知っていたものとまったく違って
最初はあまり役に立たないと
自分ではそう思ったのですが
一生懸命 栽培、醸造をやっている
皆さんの頑張っている姿を見たら
私がもうちょっと頑張れば 努力すれば
きっと役に立つことができると思って
もうちょっと やってみようと思いました
二十数年を早送りすると
今 二十数年間の —
「ココ・ファーム・こころみ」で
できたことを振り返ってみると
できたことには ある程度は納得しています
なかなか良い仕事をしていると思います
当時は３万本の生産量で
今現在は30万本まで増やしている
その上 結構 評判の良いお酒もできている
2000年の沖縄サミットで
ココ・ファームのワインを使ってもらった
そこで初めて 日本の国産ワインが
日本の公式晩餐会に使われました
その後 2006年の
北海道洞爺湖サミットにも
今年の春 G７サミット関係の広島で
ココ・ファームのワインを使ってもらいました
今日もココ・ファーム・こころみの
みなさんが
良いブドウ 良いワイン造りのために
頑張り続けています
ココ・ファームでは
色んな優秀なスタッフが入りまして
私の仕事に 割と余裕ができた
状態になったので
次のチャレンジをしようと思いました
その次のチャレンジの起源が
ココ・ファームで勤めた時に感じたことです
先程 言いましたが 生産量は
３万本から30万本に増えました
その追加分のブドウ原料の買い付けのために
私は長い間 日本列島を回っていて
いろんな地方で 農家さんと出会って
いろんな話もできて
感じたのが 日本の農業は
非常に弱い状態だということです
ますます農業の面積が減っています
ますます農作業に関わっている人数が
減少しています
先進国の中で一番 食料の自給率が
低いのは 我々日本です
このままでは日本の農業は
一方的に悪くなるということが心配で
私が次の仕事をするなら
小さい範囲でも
日本の農業に元気をつけたいと思って
2009年 妻と娘と北海道に移住して
その後 小さなワイナリーを始めました
「10R（トアール）ワイナリー」
というところです
トアールワイナリーは
ごく普通のワイナリーです
特にココ・ファームに比べると
すごくつまらないぐらい
普通のワイナリーですけど
唯一の特徴は トアールは
受託醸造専用のワイナリーということです
説明させてもらうと
普通のワイナリーのビジネスモデルを考えると
ワイナリーはブドウを用意する ―
自分で栽培するか契約農家から買って
ワインにして直接エンドユーザーの
酒屋さん、飲食店、個人客に売ります
でも 受託醸造の場合は 農家さんが
自分のブドウをワイナリーに持ってきて
一緒にワインを造らせてもらって
ワイナリーが安く農家さんに売り戻して
農家さんが自分の酒販免許を使って
エンドユーザーに自分のワインとして売ります
そうすれば農家さんの
経済状況が良くなります
１本のワインの売り上げの利益が
１キロのブドウより高くなりますから
これはしばらく農家さん達と
一緒にやると 農家さんが
自然に —
ワイン造りの技術などを
学ぶことになるし
また ワインの販路もできるので
最終的には農家さんが独立して
自分のワイナリーを立ち上げることが目的です
トアールの最大の目標がワイナリーの軒数と
畑の軒数をできるだけ増やすこと
そうすれば
北海道はワイン原産地として
より早く形成されます
ワイン原産地は
ちょっとインパクトのある動きです
ワインは色んな意味で面白い農産物です
１つはいろんな人を呼ぶ農産物です
ワインのロマンを感じる若者も呼ぶし
食いしん坊も呼ぶし
お酒好きな人も呼ぶ
ワイナリーができたら
次にワインツーリズムが始まる
ワインツーリズムが始まると
いろんな人がワイナリーへ寄ってくる
そうするとワイナリーの周辺に
レストラン、宿、農産物の直売店が増えます
それができたらワイナリーの周辺や原産地に
ちょっと丈夫な経済的状況ができて
そうすると —
農業が少し復活して
それが我々のやっていることの意味で
頑張れば 多分 —
日本の田舎を次の世代のために
守ることができるかもしれない
そう信じて今まで私たちは
こうやっています
今の話で３つの県
ニューヨーク、栃木、北海道
かなりバラバラですが
すべてに１つの共通点があります
たぶん 皆さんは
お分かりになっていると思いますが
すべては１つの小さな質問から
始まっています
その質問は
「周りの人々のために何が出来るか？」
という質問
私の父と母はそういう人たちでしたから
子どもの頃から 人間は —
お互いに助け合うことが基本だ
と教えられたので
私は実は ワインを仕事として決めたとき
このような活動は 多分仕方がなく
自分の仕事ではなく
職場以外のところでやらないといけない
と思ったんだけど
知らないうちに意図せずに
私のワインの仕事の中ででも
できるようになりました
それで皆さんは
自分の仕事 人生
たぶん今日の皆さんは
色んな活動もしていると思いますが
自分の人生 自分の仕事にも
隠れている不思議な力があるなら
それを見つけて一緒に頑張って
明るい未来に向かっていきましょう
今日は話を聞いていただいて
ありがとうございます
（拍手）